hello everyone and welcome to the final
game uh from day two this is from round
10. it's magnus carlsen vs hikaru
nakamura always a most
most welcoming matchup uh and before we
check out the game i would just like to
thank everyone for uh getting this
channel to one million subscribers it is
now official
uh there you have it a nice round number
and while i will be addressing this
maybe
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow maybe
on a rest day i want to get some time
because there's a lot to cover in this
tournament
i would just like to once again say
thank you all and
let's check out this game but we will
get to that and you know
uh everyone's been asking me okay but
now you have to reveal what agather
means and so on
uh and we'll get to that but first uh
first things first let's uh
let's check out this very nice game so
uh magnus with the white pieces opens
with
d4 uh we have knight to f6 by hikaru
c4 e6 we have knight to f3 and d5 the
queen's gambit declined this on the
board
uh we have knight to c3 and bishop to e7
uh and bishop to f4 this is carson's go
to move we have castles
and now a3 uh we have c5 by hikaru
and captures captures and this has all
been played before and it's
uh well nothing out of the ordinary here
the the usual moves are e3
and also c captures on d5 has been
played but magnus plays b4
and it is uh as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game and the good
good things always happen when someone
plays b4 as you know b4 is uh
definitely my favorite move in the
entire chess
uh so hikaru has to deal with this and
uh as he's probably never seen it before
he took some time here to consider
what's happening and then uh he decided
to move the bishop
bishop to e7 you could also offer a
trade here with bishop to d6
but he decides to keep the material on
the board so bishop e7
and only now e3 by magnus so keeping his
king in the center of the board a bit uh
a bit longer but
if it works why not so hikaru somehow
tries to take advantage of this
and goes for a5 attacking that b for
pawn that magnus so
uh happily pushed so uh a5 and here c
captures on d5 we have knight captures
on d5
knight captures and e captures on the e5
and now magnus advances his pawn to b5
uh with his king still in the center of
the board so he kind of needs to
figure out how to take advantage of this
he goes knight to d7
now he wants to play knight to c5 and
play a4 and bring his knight over to b3
and if he can do that he's going to be a
very happy chess player
so here bishop to e2 magnus is now ready
to castle and
knight to c5 now we have castles by
magnus and
now a4 preparing knight to b3 and now
bishop to e5 magnus doesn't want this
bishop to
gain control of this diagonal so he gets
bishop to e5 in
and knight to b3 uh we have the rook is
under attack so rook to a2 and
now bishop to e6 uh just continuing
development now the rooks can come into
the game
uh knight to d4 by magnus putting
pressure on the bishop also hoping to
trade here as
the knight is now attacked twice but
hikaru goes for the very tricky bishop
to d6 and this
uh definitely comes with a trick because
now if you try to win a pawn you
simply trade here and then try to win
upon knight captures
uh hikaru will not capture the knight
but rather hikaru had a d4 planned and
now
you have problems here uh best thing to
do is just give up the rook and and grab
a pawn while you're at it at night
captures bishop captures on a2
so this is what hikar was planning but
after bishop to d6 uh
magnus says all right so i can't really
do that i'm gonna go
knight captures on e6 f captures and
now only now bishop back to b2 so kind
of uh keeping the keeping the tension
but
it's still um a problem how do you get
this rook into the game as this knight
is really
excellently placed here so hikaru
continues development
rook to c8 and now g3
creating some breeding room for the king
and also this bishop and the queen here
could be
it could be a nuisance uh later on so
best just stop that with the g3
we have queen to d7 by hikaru and bishop
to d3 now now magnus also wants to put
pressure on hikaru's king side as the f
pawn is gone so the king
side is a bit weakened queen to f7 now
uh the rook has to stay here to keep an
eye on the on the f2 pawn
uh and now e4 uh and this is a very
tricky move because hikaru could play
d4 and clause of this bishop's diagonal
for good and then it's a question
what is this bishop doing for the rest
of the game and how is the rook getting
into the game
for the rest of the game but hikaru does
not play d4 he plays bishop to c5
adds a third attacker to the pawn here
and now magnus just goes e
captures on d5 so what's the idea here
why is uh
why is magnus allowing this bishop
captures an f2 well he's saying that if
captures king g2
uh your bishop is kind of stuck here you
can't move it because you lose the queen
and i might move my bishop and add
another attack here and although this is
playable
it's very complicated and for a rapid
game he car decides against it so he car
plays e captures on d5
and now again magnus doesn't want to
face uh this
d4 idea to close off his dark square
bishop so he plays bishop to e5
and the problem now is that magnus has
only three minutes left on the clock
where a c car
has some six minutes so here uh we have
rook
c to e8 and going after carlson's bishop
we have bishop to f4 and now
h6 uh so what do you play here
uh queen to g4 hikaru might have some
g5 ideas later on but it's uh it's hard
to save if it's worth it opening up the
king like that so magnus goes
queen to g4 now a lot of pressure here
on on the black king bishop captures on
h6
is always an option so here rook to e6
defending that pawn
also preparing to double up maybe rooks
on the e file maybe
triple on the f file all depending on
what white plays and here
magnus goes h4 he wants to grab more
space with h5 but hikaru doesn't allow
that he plays
h5 and pushes back carlson's queen queen
back to d1
and now comes rook to f6 and now we have
this beautiful
rook queen rook battery and uh we might
have some threats here rook captures on
f4 is definitely an idea
and here carlson goes king to g2 he says
okay for the moment
rook captures on f4 isn't all that great
but you can play it if you want
one one idea is to go knights to d4 it's
a really strong move and
what are what can you play here if not
it comes to e6 then you have
the bishop attacked four times and if
bishop to e5 putting some pressure here
then you can just play rook f3 and the
black's position is just uh
excellent another thing you could
actually capture on f4 but it's not as
forcing because after g captures and
let's say queen captures
after queen captures an h5 it's actually
black who has problems here because
there are a lot of holes here bishop to
h7 will will be deadly
so instead hikaru plays g6 uh but now uh
carlson uh gets some moves in he goes
bishop to h6
attacks the rook here rook to e8 and now
bishop to g5
pushing the rook from f6 rook after e6
now doubling up on the e file
and now a magnus plays bishop back to b1
he go he goes after sorry bishop back to
c2 he goes after the
d5 pawn with bishop to c2 but it's a
very tricky move bishop to b1 is better
because with the bishop to c2 you could
go for something like knight to d4
and then it's a problem you're no longer
attacking this and you're
threatening to pick up white's light
square bishop which is an excellent
attacker
however here uh magnus actually set a
deadly trap
the deadliest of traps and uh he's
asking hikaru are you gonna go for it
are you gonna go for rook to e1
because the rook cannot capture if the
rook captures then the f pawn is weak
and i'm just gonna capture with the
queen and here hikaru thought about it
for a minute
and then he decided yeah this is too
simple let's just play
rook to e1 and now it seems like a
carlsen is done for
but that couldn't be further from the
truth so feel free to pause the video
here
and win this game for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that wins the game for magnus
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
this is what uh magnus set up and it's
bishop
captures on g6 and when hikaru saw this
he started shaking his head as he
usually does
and of course he resigned to the game on
move 33 as there is nothing more to be
done here
the problem is whatever you do you're
just uh you're you're just completely
lost so here
what you can do is you could maybe
capture the bishop but if you capture
the bishop
then uh you capture the rookani one and
after captures captures
you you're simply up material uh you're
up upon and you have you're up the
exchange so there's really no no point
in
playing this uh white it's just too easy
for white to play this
so this obviously uh will not work uh if
you go for the bishop
on the other hand if you go for the
queen right away it's also also doesn't
work because bishop captures queen comes
with
check and after king captures rook
captures on b1 again
the the the same materials on the board
white is completely winning
and one last thing you can do after this
bishop bishop captures on g6 idea is you
could
capture on f2 with check uh but now
uh rook a captures on f2 so just rook
captures on f2 and after rook captures
on d1 you can capture this rook
and now you're simply up a whole rook so
whatever you play it doesn't work and of
course hikaru saw this
after bishop to g6 he resigned and an
excellent victory for magnus carlsen
in the final round of day two and this
is his only win today yesterday he got
four wins
today he got four draws and uh this one
win against hikaru in the final round
which
goes a long way you know uh as i mean it
is hikaru
uh and he he couldn't get a
win in on the second day so we're gonna
discuss the standings a little bit
tomorrow as i'm gonna show some more
games from
uh from today uh but that's it uh for
today
so really really uh awesome stuff it
seems uh sauron
rules supreme still uh so hope you guys
enjoyed that
i would like to thank elon chumlin minka
kim
jason visco steve green and ben white
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching
and i will see you soon uh continuing
the coverage of the
of this wonderful tournament checking up
on your one of suggestions and whatever
else happens uh in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
once again uh thank you for 1 million
subscribers
see you soon